here it is it found the champ OVA magic
being in the showerhead that's that's so
okay I really don't want to do this I
mean this movies bad really bad it's
based off of a shit TV show and you
think it can't get much lower than that
but it does it goes forward look at the
Lord look at the trailer the trailer
looks great
you got explosions monsters robots some
cool special effects this was a cool
looking movie little did we realize the
black hole of a sness that waited us all
well guess there's no way I'm avoiding
it let's look over the very
appropriately titled lost in space just
thinking about this movie makes me
cringe
everything about it's horrible the
story's horrible the writing's horrible
the acting is horrible I'd rather have a
nose job by Edward Scissorhands then
watch this pathetic pile of protoplasmic
bus but one bitch about it when I can
properly torture you by showing it this
is lost in space so it takes place in
the futuristic world of 2058 finally the
warring nations of Earth had forgotten
their differences and banded together to
save our
Wow you mean just 48 years world peace
is gonna break out I guess all the
terrorists of the world just sort of
went we're done we never good round
everybody I'm sorry if you took us so
seriously but you know we got a dark
sense of humor but as we prepared to
launch ourselves into the black of space
terrorist forces calling themselves the
global sedition preparing to strike wait
a minute whoa something the wrong peace
bullshit you said we set aside our
differences right before a terrorist
attack I guess there's no better way to
show there's no war then starting off
with a war sedition Raiders this cold
war just got hot so we see one of our
heroes played by Matt LeBlanc as we see
the future of space travel has for some
reason been reduced down to hamster
wheels show - hey so we cut to the talon
of future generic city as we see the
mother of the robinson family talked to
her son's teacher but her son is quite
the rad scallion as he can manage to
hack into any computer we didn't even
have lights this is no laughing matter
will is is terribly gifted the changing
shape of Education the products of a
totally brilliant mind monkey business
the changing shape no monkey business
it's a really hard to top this
tres real-life farm approaching no doing
it
me a while we cut to mr. Robinson played
by the astonishingly dull William Hurt
as he discusses the plans for his
dimensional portable science thingy as
you are aware alpha prime is the only
other habitable planet yet detected by
deep space recon watch as my voice
doesn't break an octave once both gates
are complete ships will be able to pass
instantaneously between them immediate
to colonization of alpha prime would be
possible there i will join kevin costner
to create a vortex of boredom now that
the missions been pushed up how do your
children feel about leaving the earth
behind they couldn't be more excited
this mission sucks
wha-wha-wha
thus were introduced to the Robinsons
daughter penny why swear to god is on an
all helium diet for the last three years
I've missed everything training so I
have been the next 10 years missing
everything else good lord it's the
missing ship hat skanky I'm not staying
home for dinner
needle sea of gems anyway she also talks
into a small camera which looks like
Facebook and YouTube have joined their
evil voices together watch world on a
deep space against her with thoughts for
the mind of the daring space captive do
they have a name for what's wrong with
you yeah the script so we see our
diabolical villain in this world of
futuristic peace whose name is dr. Smith
played by Gary I'm firing my agent
Oldman he's hired to sabotage the
Robinsons mission it will cost you and
him free
my press has just become best Renault we
call allograft off oh hey a quick
question feel free not to answer it if
you want but in the desert I mean I know
it's a hologram but why the desert can't
they just talk in a frigging room yeah
Jim Walker he's next nothing no
explanation okay well let's just listen
to these people shall giving the
illusion that the plot is moving forward
emission protocols are simple professor
Robinson is in command unless you
encounter a military Emergency in that
case major Western you are George the
block is then introduced a dr. Heather
Graham playing the character of Judy
he's heavier than Mike laughter
recalibrate I'd be happy to discuss my
dimensions doctor see over dinner I've
read about you your war hero aren't you
yes who was it who said those who can't
think fight I think that it was me yeah
well who was it who said that's one cold
fish I'd love to thaw hmm I'm not gonna
make it over for dinner tonight dad
so dr. Smith sneaks aboard and programs
the robot to kill the Robinsons
unfortunately wide-angle face here says
he's no longer needed and programs the
transmitter to knock him up but that
doesn't stop this heavy mission as the
family gets on the Tron inspired swim
suits and gets ready to launch from a
giant Jiffy Pop assume these tubes for
two there's barely enough for you and
your ego major okay how many times is he
gonna hit on mr. Robinson's daughter
when he's right there I mean that's her
father and your boss tried to keep the
appropriate raise you're looking for in
your mind so the ship launches as the
blog puts himself in deep sleep as well
no no like these freezing tubes Oh
Charlie's Angels Oh Charlie's Angels too
Oh crappy spin-off show the only last
two seasons duh so dr. Smith wakes up in
the middle of the mission but
unfortunately so does the robot did you
know
six hours into mission destroy Robinson
family announce mission objectives
repeatedly announce mission objectives
repeatedly destroy all systems
destroy Robinson family well I prefer
coffee the hat was a mistake you get no
continental breakfast
continue jaime acting continued heavy
acting so our little boy will takes
control of the robot as it turns out
judy is stuck in the freezing tube I can
save my life but OD if you give me a
word as an officer you cheaper span of
mine
so dr. Smith tries to bring her back
resisting the urge to cop a feel as it
turns out they have to go into
hyperspace to avoid the Sun's
gravitational pull if we can't go around
the Sun then we go straight through it
using your hyperdrive you can be thrown
anywhere in the galaxy
anywhere but here do
good point that right there stuck in the
not yet perfected matrix effects hello a
little movie um greenlight Wow so they
want dr. Smith away as they try to
figure out where they are what's
happened John where are we
no Kahless recap we locked dracula in
the break Joey from friends is piloting
we have a chipmunk for a daughter our
other daughter is roller girl then we
haven't even encountered the space
monkey yet boy we're in a tight spot I
don't recognize a single system we're
lost
marred we don't just do Google galaxies
they'll pick the slowest rabbit eye we
shall get there but they do come across
something a spaceship shaped like a
garden hoe so the gear up and take a
look inside they even bring the doctor
along because they're afraid to leave
them in a locked room so they'd rather
have a roaming free around arm the
weapons idiots you're coming with us
dodge it's a question I am a doctor not
a space explorer I'm a doctor not a
bricklayer give me an excuse to kill you
well I was in Hannibal so will Maja's to
control the robot as they put on their
spacesuits that will collect
suppositories to see what they can find
Captain's Log is degraded I'm not
willing to give up
Don would keep looking for me and I'm
champ
hey that's my token black guy so it
turns out their years in the future as a
rescue ship twisting out to look for
them they also come across plant life on
the ship that is evolved over the years
they've been gone she H this almost
sounds intelligent how about we put in
something really stupid and annoying
meet our comedy relief bar
like you made a friend it looks like Jar
Jar Binks aborted fetus I've tapped into
the internal sensor array there's no
other animate life present this ship is
totally deserted stop showing me that is
that really the best design they could
come up with a half-chewed Mickey Mouse
eraser come on guys a jellyfish in a
blender will look more appealing than
that hey that was PD an Andalite you
said was not on the ship oh yeah there's
no other life-forms around here except
for the giant killer spiders that have
razor-sharp teeth that will eat anything
with a brain cell so you're probably all
set to as well activate holograph
interface
hey the Nintendo was this will be
greater than the videogame they're never
gonna make but matt LeBlanc loads up and
gets ready to kick some ass
I don't need this I have a couch I could
be making crappy jokes on mic so
everybody gets to the ship and tries
their best to fly away never leave an
enemy stronghold intact major stock
that's one of your father's first rules
of engaged that is a direct order I hate
sponge nice millions of dollars in
scientific development down the toilet
why because the blockades my eaters
so the crash-land on a foreign planet is
Leblanc
really angers mr. Robinson raising his
monotone whisper to a threatening dull
roar I made a judgment call and if I
have to I'll make it again my family is
on this ship and you will follow my
orders there's that clear major I saved
your speeches I like you did we just
miss a life save your speeches I like
you
well that's going on penny in that pile
of Muppet feces really seem to hit it
off my guess is because they have the
exact same speaking voice after much
deliberation the space captive has
finally decided to accept her new role
as maid with a clue the Robinsons after
all can obviously use her health who
knows when you might need someone with a
vocal cord scraping and while that's
going on we also have to build the
romance between LeBlanc and Graham oh
yeah character development die I just
figure Belle's lost in space too when
the when the first sailors circled the
globe saw a brand-new sky i thought
they'd sailed right off the edge of the
earth so those sailors
found familiar shapes and stars to make
the sky seem more friendly that's how
the constellations were born porky the
wise and mighty Pig really did you just
come on to me with Porky Pig great big
eared bunny bugs yeah which one's the
horny skunk that never gets any I really
connect with him with the only single
man and woman of consenting age in the
galaxy do you want to show me how you
handle him Yeah right here yeah why are
you just hang on to your joystick slowly
try to figure out what could be causing
all the strange anomalies on the planet
they're on young will has an idea what
if the doorways aren't natural no this
kind of phenomenon could only be
produced naturally no that bubbles
exactly the kind of side effect I
predicted my time machine would do hmm
what if someone in this world has built
a device one I appreciate your input but
now's not the time for flights of fancy
you never listen to me
what not ever but a totally blank what
do you say well so it's Blanc and Hertz
set out to explore this planet hurt
delivers one of the most emotional
heartfelt farewells that has ever been
uttered in cinema prepare yourselves
ladies and gentlemen to be totally
entranced
I love you work ah my heart soars every
time the monotone they absolute lack of
human feeling the way he doesn't even
refer to her by her name just the roll
of white I swim every time alone you
would so they venture out into the
anomaly and discover oh god this is a
grownup version of will from the future
who has invented a time machine which is
causing the planet's anomaly the rest of
the family is dead so he has a chance to
make a reconnection with the past
version of his father this may be what a
suffice has an entire plot for another
movie but here it's just squeezed into
the last 20 minutes real Indic real rush
for time epic look father what my life
fancy huh
I used your hyper engine to build my
time they came true it looks like a
giant flaming testicle but I think I
just adds character of course of your
time machine is ripping this planet
apart is violent distortions time are
being caused by your experiment what if
it has the same effect on earth
no I'm going home
so yeah this futuristic will can build a
time machine but can't fathom the fact
that it's gonna kill everybody just how
smart is this kid anyway well apparently
not very smart as the young wheel back
at the ship is coaxed into letting dr.
Smith out and bringing him along to find
his dad could he get any stupider well
watch I'm never gonna mom's like I know
I am what we wants to have no fear in
devouring little boys testify if you
must be fully prepared to kill can't you
give me the gun enable gun for all users
you will moron he just admitted he's a
monster now you're going to give the
monster the gun yeah now you're gonna
die stupid
you're a stupid little boy how can you
make a time machine as a prank you can
make fucking beans so Smitham will make
it to the device when suddenly Smith is
confronted by his own future self
huh guys see me again after all yes
spider sting had some unexpected sir
mission three what self-loathing yes one
of the spider bites transmitted into a
monster so what does he do kill himself
by killing himself confusing if he
killed himself how could he live into
the future to do that in the first place
God who cares let's see what happens
when the future version of the robot is
ordered to kill young will do you
remember what I taught you
but friendship logic era
friendship does not compute yes forget
logic act with your heart oh my god he
didn't just say that robot has no heart
robot is powered by a fusion pulse
generator every living thing is a heart
now I know I've got the HUD because it's
breaking let us go we're all gonna die
so I'm asking you now will you be my
friend
this scene is too clichd this scene is
super same robot attempting to
deactivate control bolt come on boo me
do me
this robot has the logic of a home art
our robot can play he'll love again
robot will save his friend robot will
participate in care very inspired shit
so they find the original dr. Smith and
save his life why I don't know he's the
bad guy obviously but there you go
they say this life if they get back to
the ship Kirk goes in to stop the time
machine but the future dr. Smith has
other plans
do you think that let oh that I have big
come back within these exceptional seeds
of a master basis violence
we should descend upon helpless earth an
entire planet to rule I mean like on
which to feed so you heard right the
evil dr. Smith wants to what else take
over the world
of course but her comes in to destroy
the evil monster
hey hey okay
did this guy go to the ciclo School of
Acting fool while he was still learning
to spell your name I was being trained
he finally kills dr. Smith but
unfortunately the ship with his family
is destroyed by the debris of the planet
look at that he's so dull that the music
has to do the acting for him
well gee if only they had a time machine
to go back in a but did you wait a
minute a long time ago you told a small
boy that one day he'd understand how
much his father loved him I could never
see how much you cared I'm sorry what so
he sends his father back just a few
minutes before the family is destroyed
this way he can save them properly
remember
good to see you get off
by the way just a quick heads-up dr.
Smith was bitten by a spider he's gonna
turn to a mute and then probably try to
kill you I do with that what you will
goodbye so they fly the giant electric
razor through the plant which is odd her
could have just told them move a little
to the right to avoid the debris but
what does it matter they make it out
before the plant explodes great chop kid
that was one in a million
this was on credit
oh hey you're totally pointless so they
use their hyperspeed to blast off once
more as the seizure-inducing credits
play us out heinous this movie is
horrible one of the works I mean how can
we have this much money behind it and be
this bad I mean this bad it's right up
there with Batman and Robin I mean the
lameness factor is just off the charts
the plot is all over the map the lines
are terrible the characters are
cardboard devices it just sucks it's
lost in space it also sucks in space
affected by the time machine to go back
in time and not watch this movie you bet
your ass I would did somebody say I
machine oh hey forget it dr. Smith shit
Family Robinson might fall for your
tricks but not me I don't know what
you're talking about I'm a sweet caring
person who only wants to do good for
mankind how could anyone be stupid
enough to trust you I mean you're afraid
inspire aspire well that seems hardly
fair before me your acting was so
over-the-top all I was missing was a top
hat on the mustache the twirl
it's true that what you see is pretty
much what you get but I can be a very
persuasive person how for example there
are many dangerous monsters in this
world and I'm one of them you are yes
and don't give me your gun I'll
certainly here you go thank you
I'm dr. Smith I remember it because I'm
evil ggw here we go ha ha ha oh my I
love you work